at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by audible audible has
the largest selection of audiobooks on
the planet and I've used audible for
many many years I have several books to
recommend right off the bat ready player
one by Ernest Cline the Tao of Seneca by
Seneca if you want to hear my favorite
letters of all time put into compilation
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman if you
are a nonfiction purist and you want
something to convert you this is one
I've listened to multiple times and
right now if you're curious I'm
listening to nonviolent communication by
Marshall Rosenberg and you can tell
which one is the correct one because it
has a peace sign on the cover of the
audiobook and it's five hours and nine
minutes long this was recommended to me
by Neil Strauss multiple time New York
Times bestselling author and audible has
a lot going for it right now among other
things this is time sensitive Amazon
Prime members can get audible for just
four ninety-five a month that's four
dollars and 95 cents per month for the
first three months that's like getting
three months for the price of one and
after that it's just fourteen
ninety-five per month this offer ends
July 31st 2018 to claim this offer you
can go to audible.com slash Tim or text
Tim T I am to five hundred five hundred
to get started
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you guard Lusa
price and unused credits roll over to
the next month if you don't like a given
audiobook that you've purchased or that
you've selected you can exchange it with
no hassle whatsoever plus your
audiobooks are yours to keep forever
even if you cancel audiobooks are a
great sidekick a great secondary
activity for any number of things you
might do this summer like hiking
sunbathing hanging out on the beach
running road tripping whatever it might
be hiking outside I listen to audiobooks
a lot when I'm
on long walks dog walks cooking etc even
working out in between sets and so on
and if you're someone who likes to binge
this offer might be a good time to start
series like Game of Thrones Harry Potter
Outlander the list goes on and on so
again simply go to audible.com slash Tim
or text tim t IM to 500 500 to get
started today Amazon Prime members can
get audible for $4.95 per month for the
first three months once again that's
like getting three months for the price
one and after that it's just fourteen
ninety-five per month this offer ends
July 31st 2018 check it out
why lol now this is Tim Ferriss welcome
to another episode of the Tim Ferriss
show where it is my job normally to
deconstruct world-class performers
through interviews whether they're from
business sports entertainment military
otherwise to tease out the habits
routines favorite books and so on that
you can use in this episode I'm going to
let someone else do the heavy lifting
and he's very very qualified Reed
Hoffman on LinkedIn and Twitter as Reed
Hoffman re ID is a frequent flyer of
sorts on this show he is often referred
to as the Oracle of Silicon Valley by
tech insiders who look at his company
building and investing track record with
awe the companies include Facebook
Airbnb Zink Flickr and many many many
others Reid is well known as the
co-founder of LinkedIn which has more
than 300 million users and sold to
Microsoft for 26.2 billion dollars
prior to that he was exec vice president
at PayPal which was purchased by eBay
for 1.5 billion and at PayPal he was
nicknamed firefighter in chief by the
then CEO Peter Thiel who's also been on
the podcast and Reid is widely
considered one of the most successful
angel investors of the past decade he is
now a partner at Greylock partners a
top-tier venture capital firm and on my
phone there are very few podcasts that I
listen to multiple times there are very
few podcasts that I recommend over and
over and over again to other people
especially entrepreneurs
and what I'm going to show a case in
this episode is a conversation between
Reed and Brian Chesky who is a
co-founder and CEO of Airbnb and there
are a couple of other cameos and I'm
doing this for a number of reasons
number one if you want to learn how to
scale your company from whatever the
number might be 200 million 200 million
users paradoxically you can increase the
likelihood of success by doing things
that do not scale and this is a really
critical concept to understand and it's
best done through examples and that is
why I want to showcase this discussion
which is from the first season of
masters of scale and I really really
hope you enjoy it I loved it and Joe
Gebbia co-founder of Airbnb has been on
this podcast before and we covered his
development as a designer and an
entrepreneur leading up to the original
development of the business model for
Airbnb that was part one and I promised
a part two so this is in some ways that
part two
exactly and masters scale is a great
show if you haven't seen it it showcases
famous founders and innovative leaders
and so on sharing their lessons for
success and there is a brand new season
out right now the new season includes
episodes with founders of Spotify
Instagram TaskRabbit Shake Shack and
glossier among many many others you can
subscribe to master scale on Apple
podcasts or learn more at masters of
scale.com so without further ado please
enjoy this short episode with Reid
Hoffman Brian Chesky and many others and
if you've heard me recommend 1,000 true
fans to you many many times before as
the article you should read if you're
only going to read one article on
marketing which is by Kevin Kelly you
can find it on KK org this is the audio
complement to that so with much further
ado much further ado what much further
ado please enjoy
Joe and I are broke
we're losing weight and I know have a
lot of weight to lose you know those
binders that you put baseball cards in
we put credit cards on them at this
point I am twenty five thousand dollars
in credit card debt
Joe is tens of thousands dollars in
credit card debt so this is like
make-or-break we need the Lifeline that
[Music]
entrepreneur in need of a lifeline
that's Brian Chesky co-founder and CEO
of Airbnb a service that lets you rent a
couch for the night or a cabin or a
castle today Airbnb is valued at thirty
billion dollars eight years ago a very
different picture we have this website
and maybe 50 people a day are visiting
it and we're probably getting like 10 to
20 bucking today so and by the way been
working out for a year and a half so for
anyone who's worried your company has an
attraction that was our attraction it
was 2008 an election year in the United
States Barack Obama was running against
John McCain Brian was at the Democratic
National Convention hatching a PR
campaign for Airbnb one that could
rescue the company and on their credit
card bills Joe and I look each other we
said we're air bed-and-breakfast the air
beds aren't going so well
baby breakfast well as we thought what
if we could sell breakfast maybe we can
make some money
what's a non-perishable breakfast cereal
and so we thought the presidential
campaigns coming up we just launched the
DNC what if we created a Barack Obama
themed breakfast cereal we thought what
would a brocco bomb breakfast he'll be
called
Obama owes like Cheerios the breakfast
of chained we thought well we want to be
a nonpartisan website so we'd also have
to need a John McCain theme cereal and
that's a no-brainer
John McCain was a cap in the Navy and so
he came up with captain McCain's like
Captain Crunch a maverick and every bite
we ended up making a thousand boxes of
collectible breakfast cereal we sold
them for forty dollars a box that's
forty thousand dollars
not bad for pocket change and it got
them through a cash crunch but it came
at a cost
we had to physically make the breakfast
here ourselves meaning we get a printed
poster board and we had to fold it in
hot glue it no one told me I had a how
cool breakfast era and they should call
burn glue because every time you get on
you you burn you and I had a perfect
one-to-one ratio of burned a box and so
I literally had the hot glue a thousand
boxes cereal at one point in the middle
of the night I remember reading I wonder
if when Mark Zuckerberg started Facebook
he had a hot cool breakfast cereal the
answer was no and this was not a good
sign but what was a good sign was
Brian's willingness to work with his
hands burns and all I'd argue that
painstaking handcrafted labor is
actually the foundation of his success
in order to scale you have to do things
that don't scale you got to have
incredible talent at every position
[Music]
amazing there are so many easy ways so
it's do I have no idea what sorry you
made a mistake
but you have to time it right
ten years later
how you doing we haven't been
this is masters of scale I'm Reed
Hoffman co-founder of LinkedIn partner
Greylock and your host on this episode
I'll make the case that the only way an
organization can truly scale is the
first two things that don't scale at all
I'll try to prove that theory through
stories from some of the smartest
entrepreneurs I know over the last 20
years I've worked on or invested in many
companies that scale to a hundred
million users or more but here's the
thing you don't start with a hundred
million users you start with a few so
stop thinking big and start thinking
small hand serve your customers win them
over one by one now this may sound like
odd advice if you're an entrepreneur
with global ambitions Mark Zuckerberg
didn't personally invite 1.8 billion
people to Facebook he built a great
product and the users just poured in
right not exactly on this show I'll
dispel that myth by talking to founders
who fought to win their users I'm
starting with Brian Chesky CEO of Airbnb
because he epitomizes the idea of
handcrafting the user experience before
you start to scale it's a principle he
first absorbed in design school I was
doing medical design once I designed the
children's ventilator I had to sit in
the shoes the child and so I had to like
imagine being a child getting like the
operating table and like you have to put
yourself in the shoes of the patient or
the person using your product and if
you're only doing a/b tests like you're
never designing with empathy but a funny
thing happened to Brian when he moved to
Silicon Valley he's sort of forgot about
designing with empathy for a single user
it's a common mistake amongst
entrepreneurs with global ambitions they
have to promise investors the world tens
of millions of customers billions in
revenue it's intoxicating just listen to
Brian go this is a travel industry that
is something like 7 percent of global
GDP summer between 5 and 7 trillion
dollars 10 times the market size of
Google's market size and Brian might
have stayed in the stratosphere if not
for a fateful meeting with Paul Graham
co-founder of Y Combinator
Combinator is a startup incubator which
cultivates and invests in early-stage
companies Brian was admitted to Y
Combinator in 2009 and his first meeting
with Paul was confounding Paul tends to
stump people with deceptively simple
questions and he asked us where's your
business and I go what do you mean like
where's your traction I go well we don't
have a lot of traction he goes well
people must be using it I said there's a
few people in New York using it and he
said something I'll never forget
he said Sewer your users are in New York
and you're still in Mountain View I said
yeah he said what are you still doing
here and I go what do you mean he said
go to your users get to know them get
your customers one by one and I said but
that won't scale for hugely millions of
customers we can't meet every customer
and he said that's exactly why you
should do it now because this is the
only time you'll ever be small enough
you can meet all your customers get to
know them and make something directly
for them Brian and his co-founders
followed his advice to the letter
we literally community knew Erica
Mountain View so we would be in Wykeham
air for uh was it two night dinners and
then Wednesday Joe and I would go to New
York we literally would knock on the
doors of all of her hosts and had their
addresses we say knock knock hello hey
is Brian Joe were founders who just want
to meet you it's a little creepy just to
knock on the door on announced we need
to excuse it agin their home so they
came up with an offer that the host
couldn't refuse we'd send a professional
photographer to your home and photograph
your home of course we don't have any
money and we couldn't have played
photographers so Joe and I we just show
up the door and they're like wow this
company is pretty small these home
visits became Airbnb secret weapon it's
how they learned what people loved it's
really hard to get even ten people to
love anything but it's not hard if you
spend a ton of time with them so if I
want to make something amazing I just
spend time with you and I'm like well
what if I did this what if I did this
what if I did this from those questions
a handcrafted experience is born we'd
find out hey I don't feel comfortable
the guests I don't know who they are
well what if we had a profiles great
well what do you want your profile do I
want a photo great what else I want to
know where they work where they went to
school okay so you add that stuff and
then you literally start designing touch
point by touch point
the creation of the peer-review system
customer support all these things came
from us literally we didn't just meet
our users we live with them and I used
to joke that when you bought an iPhone
Steve Jobs didn't come sleep on your
couch but I did yes was there a
particular experience that I was really
stuck in your mind I remember we met
with a couple hosts and it's winter it's
snowing outside and we're like in snow
boots and we walk up to the apartment
and we went there to photograph the home
and we're like hey I'll upload your
photos to the website do you have any
other feedback and he comes back with a
book oh look a binder and he's got like
dozens of pages of notes and he ends up
creating like a product roadmap for us
like we should have this this this is to
this and we're like oh my god
this is our road map because he's the
customer I think that always stuck in
our mind as the road map often exists in
the minds of the users that are
designing things for them it is typical
to get very detailed feedback from some
of your early users and if you're not
getting some people who say this is
super-important to me I love this I
really need this to work well it usually
means you're off track passionate
feedback is a clue that your product
really matters to someone and one
passionate user can turn into many if
you listen to them carefully it's
essential to get this kind of feedback
early while you're still defining the
product it's like setting a foundation
as an architect you wouldn't build a
skyscraper before you've built a solid
foundation user feedback ensures you
won't build a dozen floors on an
unstable swamp brian is a simple method
for extracting detailed feedback from
users he doesn't ask what the product he
already built he asked about the product
of the dreams we'd asked these questions
like what can we do as a prize you like
what could we do not to make this better
but to make you tell everyone about it
and that answer is different if I say
what can I do to make this better
they'll say something small if I were to
say read what would it take for me to
design something that you would
literally tell every single person
you've ever encountered so you start to
ask these questions and it really helps
you think through this problem it's
essential to seek out and listen to user
feedback but the caveat is you have to
figure out which users to listen to
you're going to have different kinds of
users giving you feedback and
some of it will take you in the wrong
direction so you need to exercise
judgment in discerning will this
particular user and particular feedback
lead me to the mass-market or is it an
edge case for example at LinkedIn we had
one group of users who invent a name for
themselves they call themselves Lions
which is LinkedIn open net workers
because their theory of the world was
that everyone wants to directly connect
to everyone else in the world because
that's the way they wanted it but
they're actually not the majority case a
lot of people who are very busy who have
access to resources who have some
celebrity status do not want that and if
we followed their feedback LinkedIn
would not be where it is today
we had to steer away from a bunch of
passionate users who told us very
explicitly that we were fools for not
following their advice
if you want to build something is truly
viral you have to create a total like my
experience that you tell everyone about
and so we basically took one part of our
product and we extrapolated what what a
five-star experience being then we went
crazy so a one two or three star
experience is you get to Airbnb and no
one's there
so you knock on the door they don't open
that's a one star you know or maybe it's
a three star if they don't open you have
to wait 20 minutes and if they never
show up and you're pissed you need to
get your money back that's one store
you're never Union so it's again so a
five star experience is you knocking the
door they open the door they let you in
great that's not a big deal you're not
gonna tell every friend about it you
might say I used Airbnb it worked so we
thought what would a six star experience
be a six star experience knocking the
door the host opens hey I'm Reid welcome
my house you're the host in this case
and you would show them around and on
the table would be a welcome gift it
would be a bottle wine maybe some candy
you'd open the fridge there's water you
go to the bathroom this toiletries and
the whole thing is great that's a six
star experience and you'd say wow I love
this more than a hotel I'm definitely
gonna use Airbnb again it worked better
not expected
what's a seven star expanse knock on the
door Reid Hoffman opened get in welcome
here's my full kitchen I know you like
surfing there's a surfboard waiting for
you I've booked lessons for you it's
gonna be an amazing experience and by
the way here's my car you can use my car
and you know I also want to surprise you
but I got you this is best restaurant
the city of San Francisco I got you a
table there you're like whoa like this
is way beyond adding stars clearly
excites Brian it took some time to run
through this mental exercise we'll skip
ahead to the ten star experience so what
a 10 star check can be a chance our
check-in would be the Beatles check-in
in 1964 I'd get off the plane and they'd
be 5000 high school kids cheering my
name with cars welcoming me to the
country
I get to the front yard of your house
and they'd be a press conference for me
and I would be just a mind experience
so what would 11 star experience be I
would show up the airport and you'd be
there with Elon Musk and you're saying
you're going to space the point of the
process is that maybe 9 10 11 are not
feasible but if you go through the crazy
exercise of keep going there's some
sweet spot between they showed up and
they open the door and I went to space
that's a sweet spot and you have to
almost design the extreme to come
backwards suddenly doesn't just like
having like knowing my preferences and
having a surfboard the house seemed like
not crazy and reasonable it's actually
kind of crazy logistically but this is
the kind of stuff that creates great
experience but how far do you go toward
the 11 start experience to create the
Nirvana product all successful
entrepreneurs at some point have to come
back down to earth there's really two
stages of a startup to product the first
design a perfect experience and then you
scale that experience and that's it but
which part of the perfect experience do
you scale so the most ambitious
entrepreneurs let's call them the elan
z' after my friend Elon Musk probably
get there through raw energy because
they're convinced they need to solve a
problem and the unscalable thing is one
step that they have to push through on
the way the Elan say I'm going to Mars
but first I've got to solve this problem
right in front of me first I need to get
that rocket launched and I need to have
a business model for that first rocket
and that looks like satellites okay I'm
gonna try satellite launches and how do
I get my first rocket I need to create a
scalable rocket platform but unless I
get the first rocket up it doesn't
matter and you kind of work back to that
then you've got folks like Brian who say
I realized that to get this awesome
experience I have to Ratchet back to
something that still seems like magic
but it's totally doable and then I need
to design the elements that get me into
the totally doable thing so how does
Brian decide on the doable thing he
settled on a service with the
appropriate level of magic and started
building it and here's the next thing to
notice they didn't launch perfectly
scaled services they built everything by
hand we had a saying that you would do
everything by hand to us painful so Joe
and I we could photograph home stills
painful then we gotta photographers
though we manage them with spreadsheets
chills painful that we got an intern I
don't think I knew
how anything would grow to the level
that it did that's how we feel she's the
intern who managed those spreadsheets
she still works at Airbnb very manually
I would email the photographer and the
host and connect them and the
photographer would then send me the
photos I would go through each one
giving feedback if they needed to be
retouched and then I would manually
upload them to the host website they're
listing one by one it would take hours
to upload multitasking was the name of
the game then we automate the tools to
make her more efficient and we kind of
looked at this and we said okay what is
the easiest thing that we can automate
any little thing that changed was you
know quite a shift and what I had been
doing but for the better and I remember
one day Ryan would come to me at the end
of every day how many did we get how
many photos were shot and it was like oh
gosh I have to go through and count all
of these and then eventually a system
does everything we build a system where
now the host comes they press upon it
alerts our system which goes to a
dispatch of photographers it's all
managed through technology they get the
job they mark it through an app that we
built and then payment happens the whole
thing is automated now note how they
gradually worked out a solution
they didn't guess at what users wanted
they reacted to what users asked for and
then they met the demand through a
piecemeal process and here we come to
the true art of doing things that don't
scale it's not just a crude way of
succeeding on a shoestring budget it
also gives your team the inspiration and
urgency to build the features that users
really want I've seen this hand crafting
story play out over and over again with
entrepreneurs take my friend Patrick
Collison he's the founding CEO stripe an
online payments company today thousands
of businesses use stripe to process
payments from their online customers but
in the early days they were a scrappy
startup and Patrick paid close attention
to his users very close attention we had
a chat room where we were just help
customers with whatever issue they they
wanted to ask about and we were really
distressed after a while to notice that
occasionally people would come into the
chat room huggers sleeping
and ask question they wouldn't get any
response and so we wrote a bot that
would just page one of us if somebody
asked a question they didn't get a
response after more than 30 seconds or
something and something we're gonna
groggily the URI I'd wake up I'm like
hella bad and then go back to sleep so
in addition to being CEO Patrick had
become stripes bleary-eyed customer
service rep frustrated users would page
him at all hours it sure did not feel
glamorous you just tapping away on my
laptop for half an hour in bed actually
reminds me I don't know if you know Paul
English who founded kayak kayak is an
online travel service that finds the
lowest available rate sit cross
different websites but yeah Paul for a
number of years in kayak had his cell
phone number as the customer service
number we also had one of her there's
someone at stripe too who did exactly
the same thing now it's common for
entrepreneurs to swap stories like this
and I think it's worth dwelling on these
early days of handcrafted work because
most entrepreneurs tend to have a funny
reaction of these experiences they may
laugh about it later
they may call the work unglamorous they
may celebrate the day they could hire a
helping hand or automate these chores
out of existence but thoughtful founders
will never say what a complete waste of
time they'll often look back on this
period as one of the most creative
phases of their careers Nancy Lublin for
instance scrapple II launched an
international nonprofit from her New
York City apartment
her organization Dress for Success
started as a clothing drive for women
who needed to walk into a job interview
looking sharp and feeling confident
Nancy stockpiled sweaters on her bed and
jewelry in refrigerator and soon she was
inviting volunteers into her apartment
for informal training sessions so people
start hearing about Dress for Success
and would contact me just random people
would contact me and say I want to start
this in st. Louis I want to start this
in Hartford and I would say great you
want to come stay with me people
literally strangers would fly from st.
Louis and stay on my futon my college
futon in my tiny like law school
apartment in New York and I'd be like
how can I help and I would send them
postcards like saying like don't give up
I know it's really hard you got this I
just killed them with kindness
today Dress for Success has affiliates
and 145 cities worldwide the
let's be clear the transition from the
handcrafted phase to the massive-scale
phase is a challenging one and I wanted
to spell any illusions that you can
switch from one to the other with ease
in fact it requires two opposing
mindsets you have to fully empathize
with a single user at the same time you
have to worry about everyone I like the
way that Brian describes the difference
the designing and experience is a
different part of your brain than is
killing your spirits it's a different
skill set the scale and experience is a
highly analytical operations oriented
nicht ology oriented problem the
designing of experience is a more
intuition based human empathetic and end
experience one parallel might be writing
and editing so the handcrafted phase
tends to be more like writing it's a
more inventive and creative process
whereas the scaling phase tends to be
more analytical it's more like being an
editor at that point you tend to do more
pruning you realize well this whole
thing is magical but if we focus on this
20% we get 80% of the magic so you prune
you compact you distill and you
architect so can now run at a rocketship
rate you're transitioning the product or
service over to a scale organization
that can now run it the organization
needs a simple plan with very few errors
and very little improvisation now you
might think the first step design the
ideal user experience drops away as soon
as your product goes viral
then comes the glamorous work of
expanding new countries and thinking
about your strategy in the years ahead
handcrafted work is essentially a kind
of booster rocket that helps you get an
orbit but it's not the kind of rocket
for the whole trajectory it gets you out
of the gravity well and after that get
ready to slingshot around the world we
became an international company then
middle 2011 we raise money we're like
this billion dollar valuation company
and then in summer 2011 a woman's home
got trashed and then we had to go the
next step which was we are just this
little company apartment but as far as
the world is concerned we have a giant
office building we better be grownups so
we had to build 24/7 support had to have
more secure payment instruments we had
to add a trusted safety team we had to
verify people's identity we realized we
have to get our money transmission
licenses so then there's this whole like
administrative bureaucracy that gets
added then 2012 we get to the point
where we have like 50 hundred employees
we have no executive team there's no
management there's no like company
meetings there's no communication so no
one knows anything I don't know anything
like look literally nothing I don't even
know how we ran the company and so I
instituted some basic things like I have
to have an executive team and then the
lawsuits come in and you have to really
sort it out and unfortunately we're not
regulate the federal level we're a girl
you at the city level and every city is
different and they're like I see what
you do in Paris but here in New York
we're different and so you go city by
city you've got to hire those people to
really triage and deal with all these
issues it's like a video game you slay a
dragon
you think you've completed the board
game and then you the next level and all
of a sudden the Dragons get really big
but when you're slaying dragons it's
hard to hold on to the handcrafted
mindset still I would argue that the
sharpest founders never fully abandon
the mindset no matter how big their
company gets and so the organization
will start having antibodies against new
handcrafted things it's a response that
protects organizational efficiency it
says look this new thing we can't get it
to scale it won't operationalize it
won't fit within our process
the reason the scaled companies have a
hard time with this handcrafted process
is all in the list of objections about
why this won't work why this shouldn't
be integrated as part of the company and
so what you need to do as the founders
be extremely choice 'full about which
handcrafted innovation you choose and
how you protect it organizationally you
need to protect it because the natural
reaction of the scale organization will
be to kill it he wanted to reinvent the
industry again and he knew he had more
to learn about the travel experience in
order to do it why don't that so he
turned the Hollywood for help
I often find that to reinvent an
industry you do not take inspiration
directly from that industry that you
need to look at orthogonal industries
and for us the orthogonal industry to
travel with cinema and the best ships
you've ever seen are the trips that
characters and movies have and that we
would provide that analogy in real life
and I actually literally hired a
storyboard artisan Pixar and we had him
story where the perfect care of me
experience when we did that we realized
there was like this to our movie and
only 20 minutes were in the home there
was all this like leading up to the home
getting the airport going around going
to dinner hanging out with friends out
and about and like most the trip was not
in the home but we realized that point
we need to be in the end end business of
travel so the same way that he did
things to don't scale we called it
magical trips we decided let's find one
traveler and create the perfect trip for
them notice how quickly Brian turns his
attention to a single traveler in an
instant he switches from global concerns
back to his artisanal roots and that's
because he's building something
radically new here he wants to scale the
perfect trip but what is the perfect
trip what are the essential ingredients
that make a vacation truly memorable
it's a question that Brian can't even
begin to answer until he delivers that
experience to at least one person you're
about to get a masterclass in hand
crafting and so we put up these Flyers
as anonymously saying seeking a traveler
will photograph your trip to San
Francisco if you let us follow you this
guy Murr Ricardo replied she was from
London and we sent a photographer around
him while he was just traveling to San
Francisco what we learned was his trip
was awful like he'd show up you go to
Alcatraz by himself put on the headset
and they go to Bubblegum's shrimp he's
staying like like budget hotel he'd go
to a hotel bar by himself like sitting
like with a bunch of dudes at the bar
he didn't talk to anyone because he's
introverted we call him back we said
Ricardo we want to create the perfect
trip to San Francisco for you you fly
him back and we had the team storyboard
the perfect experience for Airbnb we had
a driver pick him up the airport and we
took him to the perfect Airbnb there all
these services he went on these dinner
parties we gotten the best seats at
restaurant we took him on this midnight
mystery bike tour like 60 riders go on
it and nobody but the leader knows what
will end up and it's just like there was
this crazy magical world I see him at
the end of the trip I say how was your
trip he says was amazing and then I walk
away yells at me Brian one more thing
and he starts like crying and he breaks
ties - thank you this is the best trip
I've ever had as I go my god I guess it
kind of kind of worked like it really
moved him because I don't think anyone
ever tried to like design end to end
experience or somebody like they're in a
movie before and we did it that became a
blueprint and we said we are confident
on an unscalable basis that we know how
to create a trip that deeply moved
somebody's better than anything they've
ever experienced the question is can we
develop a technology skills and do a
hundred million times notice here how
quickly Brian switches back to the
analytic mindset he can extrapolate from
a single journey to a list of essential
ingredients here is a systemic breakdown
of the perfect trip when you first go to
city you need a welcome event within the
first 24-48 hours we are around people
the day when you land you get acclimated
to the neighborhood that by day 2 or 3
you need to have a challenge out of your
comfort zone if you do not leave your
comfort zone you do not remember the
trip and if you can belong out of your
comfort zone and something new happens
to you then there's gonna be a moment of
transformation where the person you were
in a small way dies and a new better
version yourself is reborn now this is
the narrative of every movie ever seen a
main character starts in the ordinary
world they leave their ordinary world
they cross the threshold to a new
magical world where all these obstacles
happen
and they overcome something and they
call it the hero's journey and we
applied this to trips build a small team
and we spent the last couple years
figuring out how to scale this and this
has led to what we have today which we
call Airbnb trips in November of 2016
Brian unveiled 500 ship packages in 12
cities and now he's fully in the scaling
mindset figure out how to expand the
service to new destinations but as Brian
will tell you he misses the handcrafted
work he is a surprising message for
entrepreneurs who have only a handful of
users to serve I kind of tell a lot of
entrepreneurs who don't have traction I
missed those times I mean it yes it's
exciting that traction have a super like
companies like huge scale but the
biggest leaps you ever get as when
you're small and another way of saying
is your product changes less the bigger
you get because there's bigger more
customers more blowback more systems
more legacy the most innovative leaps
you'll ever make often especially for
your network are gonna be when you're
really really small you can change the
protocol entirely in a week try doing
that at LinkedIn or Airbnb today it'd be
a huge disaster so I think taking
advantage of that subscale designing the
perfect experience asking yourself what
you could do is amazing and if you have
a teeny start-up I have good news for
you now is the moment you can take the
most daring leap to your career dream
big and act small pay passionate
attention to your users
handcraft the core service for them
create a magical experience and then
figure out what part of that magical
handcrafted thing can scale
[Music]
I'm Reed Hoffman thank you for listening
[Music]
masters of scale is a wait what original
our executive producers are June Cohen
and Darren Tripp our producers are Dan
CAD me Jenny Cataldo and Ben Manila
special thanks to jessicajohnston sada
sepi Ewa Alisa Schreiber Chris Shay
David Sanford Jay Punjabi Stephanie Kent
and Rafi naman original music is by the
holiday of mothers mixing and mastering
by brian pew visit masters of skill calm
to find a transcript for this episode
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday if that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek calm that's
4-hour workweek calm all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible audible has the largest
selection of audiobooks on the planet
and I've used audible for many many
years I have several books to recommend
right off the bat ready player one by
Ernest Cline the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time put into compilation the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman if you are
a nonfiction purist and you want
something to convert you this is one
I've listened to multiple times and
right now too curious I'm listening to
non-violent communicate
by Marshall Rosenberg and you can tell
which one is the correct one because it
has a peace sign on the cover of the
audiobook and it's five hours and nine
minutes long this was recommended to me
by neil strauss multiple time New York
Times bestselling author and the audible
has a lot going for it right now
among other things this is time
sensitive Amazon Prime members can get
audible for just four ninety-five a
month that's four dollars and ninety
five cents per month for the first three
months that's like getting three months
for the price of one and after that it's
just 14.95 per month this offer ends
July 31st 2018 to claim this offer you
can go to audible.com slash Tim or text
Tim T I am to five hundred five hundred
to get started
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you guard listen
price and unused credits roll over to
the next month if you don't like a given
audiobook that you've purchased or that
you've selected you can exchange it with
no hassle whatsoever plus your
audiobooks are yours to keep forever
even if you cancel audiobooks are a
great sidekick a great secondary
activity for any number of things you
might do this summer like hiking
sunbathing hanging out on the beach
running road tripping whatever it might
be hiking outside I listen to audiobooks
a lot when I'm going on long walks dog
walks cooking etc even working out in
between sets and so on if you're someone
who likes to binge this offer might be a
good time to start series like Game of
Thrones Potter Outlander the list goes
on and on so again simply go to
audible.com slash Tim or text Tim T I am
to five hundred five hundred to get
started today Amazon Prime members can
get audible for $4.95 per month for the
first three months once again that's
like getting three months for the price
of one and after that it's just fourteen
ninety-five per month this offer ends
July 31st 2018 check it out
you
you